forecast good morning to you sir your
most accurate weather now forecast
beginning with this great view of
the flag that's not doing much of
anything at this moment
on the corner of rainbow and west lift
it's around the rainbow curve in the 95
on top of the bank of america building
so a couple of hours
ago yeah there was a lot of wind we
expect the wind will pick up but for now
there's a brief respite officially we're
at 51 degrees out at mccarran
but what's happening in your
neighborhood well we've got 44 at the
air force base
45 aliante but lots of 50 still 54 for
the strip mountain's edge as well the
lakes are hanging at 55. we'll see if
these temperatures drop here
before they turn back around and start
heading up to upon near record high
temperatures
death valley probably going to be
hitting in the 80s again over the hump
and prompt you're at 45 same thing for
boulder ely is dropping a little bit but
that's the warm before the wind and
caliente
you guys may see some rain mixed with
snow and very strong wind
down here we're talking about just a
couple of breezes we're going 56
after 74 yesterday that's 10 degrees
above normal
not a real threat to the record but
certainly getting into that territory
our current temperature
the low so far this morning yeah this is
a powerful system coming on shore just
not much impact for us
big time rain for northern california
coastal sections of washington and
oregon
and some good news for your family and
friends across the nation a fairly quiet
weather day
so we have time to head on down to
central america now hurricane iota is a
category one storm with sustained winds
of 85 miles an hour now remember ada
tracked to the north and ended up
hitting florida iota is expected to go
directly west across central america and
into the pacific
your seven-day forecast will warm it up
and even windier tomorrow gusts may
reach 30 and some neighborhoods will hit
80.
behind that we cool off how about 66 for
saturday believe it or not that's normal
for this time of year
and then maybe 63 for monday